I call it the 3mon slump where you're
ripping in for the first 2 months and
then the third month is always you the
bed you know they ripping in for eight
weeks they've got all the adrenaline and
they're crushing it and then they think
that this is freaking easy and then they
go through this slump period where
they're like Wow have I just made a
really bad decision here or it's way
less than than I got for the for the
first two months you know sometimes it
happens in the second month sometimes it
happens in the fourth month but
generally you know around the third
month area let their foot off the gas
and then they start getting creative and
cute with being a business owner oh I'm
going to start a podcast I'm going to
start doing lots of LinkedIn posts I'm
going to go to networking events and
whilst they all are really valuable
things to do in recruitment when you're
in your first like 6 12 months of
starting your business the only thing
you can really think about is just
getting money in the door and sticking
to General recruitment activities the
basics